guys think Trump's back
Trump is back 2016 question that's a
complicated question I mean how is he
going to pull with the American people
overall I don't know I will say this was
good for him this was very good for him
best day since I heard someone's on the
on the way in I heard someone talking
about it the best day since he went to
Ohio
what was Ohio the meeting went to the
Ohio wind at the train derailing oh
right right right right yeah absolutely
this this brought back a lot of that
energy in the beginning it was a little
slow it was a little I was like oh come
on man and then in the end he's standing
up and he's like no no boy you're a
nasty woman was a nasty person something
like that is like you're very nasty he
says like oh boy are you nasty something
along those lines
because what we're getting out of this
town hall is a guy kind of giving us
legitimate answers look I don't do you
want Ukraine to win the war I want
people to stop dying oh oh now now even
Newsweek has it look at this that's a
very good diplomatic answer to that
right because because do you want to go
ahead and be like yeah we have to smash
Russia